MALE SPEAKER 1: The amount of
content that's been created
has exploded.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH:
That's exciting.
MALE SPEAKER 2: And they'll
broadcast that information
one to ten times a second.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1:
We need to make sure
that this data gets into the
hands of as many people as
possible.
MALE SPEAKER 3: And here's
where you developers come in.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: The
App Universe is enormous.
MALE SPEAKER 4: Your
life as a developer
can be easier and more
successful by taking advantage
of our guidance.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: So
you can make decisions
based on concrete data.
MALE SPEAKER 5: With
this one weird trick.
[GRUNTING]
MALE SPEAKER 6: That's nuts.
MALE SPEAKER 3:
Every single release
has new stuff that
you can talk about.
MALE SPEAKER 6: And in the
process of that you may
forget your personal security.
[BOXING BELL RINGS]
MALE SPEAKER 4: The best
practices are important,
and we really
thought them through.
MALE SPEAKER 5: Let's
see this in action.
MALE SPEAKER 6: Can
we roll that video?
[CAR BRAKES SCREECHING]
[BIRD SQUAWKING]
MALE SPEAKER 7: Guilty.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: And that's it.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Join us.
ANDREW BUNNER: We can't
wait to see what you build.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3:
Thank you for watching.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.